because the bloody intellectual leftists
have never apologized for their
complicity in the catastrophes of the
20th century the Germans apologized
sorry about the Nazis for the lesbian
intellectuals they say well that was
real dealt with real Marxism it's like
oh ok how many corpses have to pile up
around you before you're willing to
question you the love is ideological
presuppositions and face your resentment
and your narcissism and your desire for
destruction you don't like people anyway
the planet has too many of them so like
ignites war might clear that up well
then all the plants can grow again you
know this part of Rome we talked about
the population explosion it was going to
wipe out the planet by the year 2000
they say outright that human beings
we're a cancer on the planet lots of
people think that it's like oh boy let's
put the atom bomb holding your hand
human beings are a cancer on the planet
what a hell of a thing to say you say
that to a four-year-old
I saw bloody professor at Queen's
University tell a whole roomful of
18-year olds that if they had an ethical
fiber in their body they wouldn't have
any kids
or they only have one because all
they're doing is going out there and
raising the planet it's like what you
know what the hell what I understand
that it's like human beings are hard on
the planet but it's pretty damn hard on
house in return you know it's like we're
just sort of trying not to die too
miserably and we make a bit of a mess
well doing this but yeah crazy only
known for 50 years that we were
disrupting the ocean how fast do you
think we can learn you know 100 years
ago talking talk please who was a great
biologist that the oceans are so
plentiful it was not a chance we could
ever put a dampener
sar only 100 years ago 50 years ago we
thought oh man there's more
and we're better at this than we thought
like okay how fast you expect people to
learn you know one generation one year
we're trying to do our best most most
people are trying to do best something
learn try to do the worst but mostly
returns to disaster and so Jeff a little
compassion look sympathy for human
beings instead of considering ourselves
like raping patriarchal oppressive
destroyers of the world Jesus